because Saoirse Ronan you all's you want
a really good prize and what did you win
I won a trip to Florida when I was a kid
how you want it I will I want it when I
was when I was a kid and I had never
entered into a competition like that
before and it was the first day of the
summer holidays when I was I was like 9
or 10 or something and Jerry Ryan who
you know was this very well-known Irish
DJ at home he's passed away now but he
was really incredible and his show was
like the top shell in the country and
Shrek 2 had just come out that's how
long ago was and he was given away this
holiday to Florida and what you had to
do was you had to phone in as one of the
characters and Shrek 2 and tell Jerry
why you deserved the holiday and I
haven't started properly actin yet at
that stage or anything but dad was an
actress so I was around through like you
know improvisers and things like that
and I was like you should go in first
just why not we had never been on like a
proper holiday oh god okay so we got a
little notepad like tiny little notepad
and we wrote down like a tiny little
script of what I was gonna say just the
short little script and they got on and
I think I was one of the first kids on
and I and I did it as the gingerbread
man and and so then five days later he
he found up and told me that
well you were on The Late Late back in
Ireland they found this clip so this is
this is two little clips put together
this it's your gingerbread man yeah
followed by which I read like your
reaction to winning is very squeaky
voice now Saoirse is ten years of age
now which character of you chosen
[Music]
oh you Jewish the reason why I need a
holiday
[Music]
well I've got news for you you're going
to Florida
when you win an Oscar I want you to
react like that I also got a blow-up
donkey halfway through the week so
that's what I was like I'm out of it
then if they've sent me a blow-up donkey
I had this like this this donkey that
went up to it and I brought him into
school and everything I was like I
haven't worn the prize but at least I
got this yes yes
[Music]